Okay so by way of wrapping up on this
let me just point out three quick facts
about correlated equilibrium.
>> Cool.
>> Okay, so here's the first one,
correlated equilibria or C.E.
as a cool kids call them can
be found in poly of the time.
So this is a good thing
even though I didn't
tell you how I found the one third,
one third,
one third, zero correlated
equilibrium in the previous example.
You can find that in
a reasonable amount of time.
I found it in even more
reasonable amount of time,
which is I looked at the example and
I wrote down the numbers.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Which is also polynomial.
Okay, in fact it's linear.
Okay, so.
>> And that's not so
true of Nash equilibria,
that Nash equilibria are hard to find.
>> Yes, they are which is unfortunate.
>> No but it, okay, it gets a nice
advantage of correlated equilibrium.
>> That's true but Nash sounds so cool.
Well in any case.
Okay, the second fact is all mixed Nash
equilibria are in fact correlated.
So this means that correlated
equilibiria exist.
That comes from what we discussed or
that there's always at least
a possibly mixed Nash equilibria.
>> Cool.
>> And of course pure Nash equilibria
are themselves mixed Nash equilibria.
Therefore correlated equilibria exist.
>> Gotcha.
>> Okay.
Finally.
>> Wait, pure in the sense of
the original definition of.
>> Right exactly.
>> Okay.
>> And
then the third one is, and
this kind of follows from probability,
all convex combinations of mixed Nash
equilibria are in fact correlated.
>> Whoa, okay.
>> There's a lot there and
we could talk about it forever but
the basic idea is that correlated
equilibria is kind of cool traffic
lights are not a bad idea and coming
up with them isn't impossibly hard.
Unlike all that other stuff you
talked about before with POMDPs
where there are undecidable and
life is terrible
at least here we can actually find
pretty good correlated equilibrium.
Or at least we can find
correlated equilibrium.
>> That's a relief.
>> It is a relief.
>> Okay, so I think I'm ready
to go on to the next thing.